[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everybody for those out in
the audience please take your seats the
program the procession will be coming in
a bit good morning this is our first
time ever we're we're going to be doing
a live color commentary of the
procession as the students the faculty
and the administration and our honor and
walk through the camp block campus and
into Old Campus this is the 317th
commencement and here with me is penny
Lorenz dr. Lawrence is a senior advisor
to the University and a former head of
Jonathan Edwards College penny can you
explain the history of the commencement
and of old campus sure first let me say
good morning Eileen good morning
everybody watching livestream and
everybody on the old campus we have an
absolutely beautiful morning just about
perfect for commencement I would say
maybe a little too much sun in places
but other than that a sparkling day and
we are sitting here on the old campus of
the university which is the oldest part
of the university straight ahead of me
I can see Connecticut Hall which is the
oldest building on the university 1701
and across from that McClellan and
surrounding us here are all the freshman
dormitories for 10 of the 14 colleges so
we're sitting there with Farnum and
Lawrence and Durfee and we always think
it's fitting that the youngest people
who come to Yale some of the youngest
live on the oldest part of the campus so
actually commencement started in a
church not surprisingly and it moved
then to Battelle chapel when the numbers
got too big for the original church and
then in nineteen then it moved to
Woolsey Hall where it could hold the
graduating seniors and the rest of the
university
and finally and at long last it moved to
the old campus when there came too many
graduates to actually sit in the great
old Woolsey Hall so we're here today on
the old campus there are about 20,000
chairs here
between 18,000 and 20,000 we have three
thousand seven hundred and twenty-eight
graduates thirteen hundred and sixty of
them are undergraduates and then we have
the graduates from all the professional
schools and graduate schools of the
University
so Yale has an undergraduate body a
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences and
that it has 12 professional schools
there's art architecture music drama
divinity Forestry and environmental
studies medicine nursing Public Health
Engineering and Applied Sciences and all
of those schools and at the business I
hope I said business and law and all
those schools are graduating this
morning so it's a so as we can see all
of the graduates actually coming down
towards the where the procession and
will actually walk through them but yes
and a long and historic tradition so
what we're seeing now on the screen is I
believe it's Noah Porter gate and
through that gate eventually will come
the processions and what will happen now
is that the graduate schools
are gathering on the cross campus and in
the residential colleges Dean's and
heads are lining up all their students
and they're processing them with their
flags we can see a college here I can't
see what it is I think it may be Pauli
Murray or Franklin processing into the
old campus and eventually all the
graduates will be there and ultimately
we'll see on screen the procession with
the President and provost the officers
the honor ends march through the members
of the graduate schools of Arts and
Sciences in the professional schools and
then the undergraduates will form a big
chain around the New Haven green right
which the procession will go through so
what if the undergraduates been doing
for the last couple of days beyond
celebrating of yours yeah so the
undergraduates have had a long weekend a
lot of people arrived Friday we're
sorry' out there if you're already
exhausted there's only a short time
before you see your students actually
get a degree and they had a
baccalaureate service which goes back to
the very initial beginnings of Yale in
which the president spoke and the Dean
made remarks they heard some beautiful
glee club and we'll see all now the
class is so big we have to and so many
visitors come to Yale to see it that we
actually have to do it in three
installments right so they had a
wonderful baccalaureate service this is
the undergraduates and then on Saturday
morning there was a Phi Beta Kappa
ceremony and following that another
baccalaureate and then the president met
all the undergraduates and the Dean of
Yale College at a reception and shook
their hands and had a wonderful time
with them but this is also a culmination
of practically a whole year's worth of
extra activities for the seniors as a
former head of college yes can you
talk about what's that like to organize
for them well on this weekend a lot of
the extracurricular groups that have
seniors in them do special things
special performances the glee club has a
marvelous performance the band sits out
in the evening and does a wonderful
performance and by the way everybody to
our left here which I don't think you
can see is the band tent and the entire
band is sitting under there or will be
sitting under there right now they've
gone to lead the procession so that the
procession will actually have music
right and beside we saw the tuba is a
few minutes ago so besides the band in
the glee club in addition to that
there's an absolutely fabulous
undergraduate musical show that
commencement musical this year it was
Stephen Sondheim's into the woods and
the remarkable thing about this is that
they basically put it up in ten days and
I went to see it I saw it on Friday
night and it's virtually a professional
show so we had an absolutely wonderful
time watching that and the Whiffenpoofs
and women rhythm had a concert and all
over the campus seniors are showing off
their whatever it is they're they're
involved in at the same time by the way
we had the men's lacrosse team yes
winning against Loyola and they are now
going next week to the national
championship to the playoff with a
championship yeah so penny to the what
yesterday was a very special day it was
class day and I think you're gonna see
in the crowd still a lot of wacky hats
but the hats really came out yesterday
yes you can see them online it is a
tradition at Yale and no one knows where
it started that the undergraduates at
class day wear hats and if you look
online you can see a wide array of
beautiful funny amusing hats they're
worn by all the undergrad
and also by all the deans and all the
heads of colleges and they really are
hilarious I think we should say at the
same time that we're not just
concentrating on undergraduates here
right exactly because in the great
graduate and professional schools many
different things are going on over the
weekend
people are celebrating in many different
ways and there are thousands of friends
and family here from these great
graduate and professional schools who
are here to see their children graduate
so just so that people know too as
though as the ceremonies begin we won't
be doing the commentary at that point
but so what do they can they expect I
mean do the the each student is not
gonna go cook no no so that would be
really long right so Yale's
commencement ceremony itself the one
that takes place here on the old campus
is very formal and ritualized it's one
of the most formal celebrity events of
the year
it's very choreographed and the first
thing that you'll see that really begins
the celebration will be flags coming
down this middle aisle here oh now we're
looking at Phelps gate this is where the
procession will enter the undergraduates
after they march around the green will
enter from here Phelps gate and I see
some of the many people at work on
commit it takes a gigantic team to make
this happen and a lot of the marshals
and the people who run this are people
who have for years and years been
involved in the commencement procession
so we're seeing you members of the
audience and at home you can see members
of the audience and we're seeing the big
gateway where eventually the procession
will come in the procession will also
have the each of the undergraduate
college has a lot of symbolism they have
shields that what what does each shield
represent well just to tell you there
was yell has a drum
this number of shields and flags that
you will see and that is because it had
somebody a professor of art history
called a purse we want of arms
Teddy sizer and he actually created many
of the shields and flags you will see
today that's a long history of Heller
heraldry and of course every school has
certain flags and banners and things
that they used to symbolize or represent
the institution but Yale has a
tremendous number of them and that's
because we did have a horse we vaunt of
arms and he began creating some of these
amazing flags that you will see and so
on the coat of arms at least for the
residential colleges there's now 14 and
the last two actually were designed by
John Gamble who was the university
printer and I think with the iconography
on these are on these shields is if
really you think a lot about it because
it represents the name of the college
and the history of the person for whom
that college is named which i think is
also very very special because it a lot
of it is about their careers and their
lives which is meant to inspire the
students who who live there very shortly
the procession is about to step off from
where sterling library where the honor
ends and the administration and officers
and the and the corporation or the what
we call the corporation and the Board of
Trustees are have all been getting on
their academic robes and they will very
shortly step out from from Sterling
Memorial Library
so Jonathan Edwards she'll tell us a
little bit about that well the flag of
Jonathan Edwards which was the
residential college of which I was head
has a lion rampant on it and that is
part of the history of Jonathan Edwards
own family as you said they take
symbolism from the name of the head of
college and try to use it so when you
see a big green dragon or lion rampant
on a flag I will be cheering because
that will be my College every college
has
flag and a color but we should also say
all the graduates that golf also have
marvelous flags and marvelous insignia
heraldry and so often when you spot the
flag you can recognize who is entering
the old campus and each of the schools
also has amazed yes oh my goodness we're
going to see a very big mace today that
weighs 24 pounds each school and the
undergraduate colleges appoint marshals
and these marshals are often people who
are being honored in some way the chief
marshal will be an administrator of the
school or it's usually not the Dean of
the school and there will be student
marshals as well and then there are
procession marshals
there are marshals for marshals who are
showing everybody where to go and who
are honored by being allowed to carry
these Mason quite an honor and two new
maces were designed in fact just like
two new shields for the two new
residential colleges Pauli's Murray mace
was designed by a Vermont based master
sculptor and a wood carver Michele hafsa
fell and she chose a piece of wood from
the property in Vermont part of a small
maple that had actually been strangled
by a bittersweet want-want
vine and when turned and polished it
looks like a narwhal tusk with a big
turn so it it was the same shapes that
appear in the chief of an new polymerase
shield we also may want to talk about
the roads what are in fact all these
robes that people are wearing and how
how do you identify what school or what
they represent
well the undergraduates all wear black
gowns and white hoods some of most white
hoods and some yellow hoods symbolizing
the liberal arts the white hoods
symbolized the liberal arts
and the pH DS and the J DS and the
people who have what we call terminal
degrees the graduates wear robes the
color of the institution from which they
got the degree yes mine is red because
crimson really because mine is a Harvard
degree but in fact even though I've been
at Yale for 45 years I still have to
wear or wear the color of the school
that awarded me the degree yeah and you
are wearing I am wearing the colors for
Georgetown and Georgetown a law degree a
Georgetown law and by the way you can
identify what school is coming in not
only by the flag but by the colors that
they're swearing so as Eileen is wearing
a purple hood from the law degree yes
and when you see people marching and you
see all the purple hoods you will know
that they're from law if they're green
they're from medicine if they're gold
for their from science or engineering if
they're brown
they're either music or no no not music
drama or architecture if they're pink
they're music so you know if they're
russet they're forestry management is
sapphire blue Nursing is apricot Public
Health is a salmon pink I don't know if
I can really tell the differences
between the shades of salmon and pink in
but I think when you see them marching
on the campus in great numbers you'll
see that that makes a big difference so
you can see the the police and the
colors now are ready ready and waiting
for the procession to step off from
Sterling Memorial Library at the head of
that procession there at Noah Porter
gate is Kate courier she's carrying
something called the Yale
the Yale has a funny looking head on it
and it is supposed to represent a
mythical or mystical beast and here they
go with the procession marshal Kate
career leading the way with Alan Kazdin
a very very important professor of
psychology was retiring this year and
here come the banners the heist and
banners the university banners and in
back of that Tom Duffy leading the Yale
man
they are heading towards the green where
they're going to stand around the green
and meanwhile back of them
the procession with all the honor ends
and the president of the provost and the
officers they're all walking from
Sterling Memorial Library and walking
through the Graduate School staring and
you can the people who are carrying the
banners also received awards at class
Day ceremony now here comes Jonathan
Edwards College my college and silliman
is next to them two colleges at a time
so you people at home were looking for
students you're looking at Jonathan
Edwards college and silliman College and
Jonathan Edwards on the fellows are
marching first so what are the noodles
everyone's waving those are well every
college sometimes orders special things
Jonathan Edwards actually has some green
flags you'll see and everybody else in
silliman seems to have these noodles
which they will wave in the when they
get into the old campus and when their
degrees are announced we also have a new
symbol for Grace Hopper College because
that was a renaming of what was formerly
known as Calhoun college and
hers--hers-- shield the shield for that
college is actually based on her work as
a computer scientist and one of the one
of the pioneers of computer languages so
you're gonna see circles and dashes was
represent the code on the back of her
shield as well as a fish because she was
an admiral in the Navy that Jonathan
Edwards colleges is is passed and the
two colleges were seeing our it's
Brantford Istanbul College yes Trumbull
and Brantford you see all the fellows
the fellows our faculty members and
associates at the college who form of
fellowship of the college and faculty
have the opportunity either to march
with their own residential college all
faculty who wish to be are associated
with a college or they can march with
their own school or with the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences so yep here come
Trumbull and so the in addition to the
flags that there are also who else gets
to hold the maces of each of the
residential colleges that's a special
honor as well yes well there is a mace
held by the Dean of each residential
college not the head but the Dean who's
the leader of the students who has
helped these students finish their
degrees and seem to their academic and
personal success and they hold the
college mace and there are two students
who are also marshals and you will see
them later because they will be the ones
honored to come up on the stage
represent their classes and actually
receive the degrees from the president
they will symbolize the rest of the
class and that's because they have the
highest academic standing in their
residential not always it's it's it's
people who certainly have good academic
they're they're chosen because they're
leaders of their college in some way
there's also a banner bearer and often
the banner bearer is held by the heist
and by the heist and pride and the flags
that we're seeing right now represent
let me see what we see
Berkeley I believe right and
TD next to them let me see who's there
so as you can see some of the students
have also embellished their hats
particularly from that it's the Pearson
College has the sons on their hats we'll
have to ask some of the students what
the symbol of that is it's a pun
apparently on the name Pearson these
stoles that they're wearing have become
a tradition or have become used by some
colleges in the past few years
technically you're not supposed to wear
these on your gowns but one college I
won't mention which one started it is
that yours it might be and now a number
of other colleges have picked it up I'm
waiting for the current course we want
of arms at Yale to stop this tradition
it could happen but it's a there's a lot
of rules and regulations about the gown
yes
see these two as say Brook and Moore's
are coming down and there is handsome
Dan there is handsome Dan yes a puppy
actually well he's slightly older than a
puppy now he's about a year and a half
old he's marching with his college he's
a Moore's fellow I see Catherine Panther
brick he's the head of Moore's and
severe Stellos are coming through and
the handsome Dan is a mascot that he
actually Yale was the first University
in the United States to adopt a mascot
that history of handsome Dan dates back
to 1880
when Andrew Graves 90 of the class of 92
1892 that is a football player and rower
during the days of Walter Camp first
name Yale's mascot
he became the mascot and the handsome
great can't andrew graves saw the dogs
sitting in front of a shop and he
purchased him from New Haven blacksmith
by the way other stoles you see here are
from the African American graduation the
other night I see some Native American
stoles and these are from the cultural
has these are from the cultural houses
yes awards from the cultural houses were
stoles from the cultural houses from
students involved and let's see some of
these colleges are so here I think comes
the Grace Hopper banner yes
which as alumni and you can go by either
Grace Hopper and with them with the
Grace Hopper you can see that it's as
we're styles
there you can see those dots and dashes
and you can see the fish on the Yale
blue background so there go Julia Adams
they had a popper and Steve pitty ahead
of Stiles
and all their students behind them and I
see that this year there are flags held
this is getting to be a tradition to all
different kinds of things that
and by the way when we see the graduate
and professional schools
we'll see this year of Forestry and
environmental studies where's greenery
on the top of their caps sometimes they
do that sometimes the Divinity School
students wear halos so there are lots of
different things you'll see that people
have added and in the form of Gallia
right and that professional skills like
the nursing school is also usually had
some pretty unusual hats so there some
of them also carry a New Haven flag yes
so the people who won the high stand
Awards yesterday that is to say the ward
for the highest average in the social
science the humanities the sciences
extraordinary students in the arts I
always say when you win one of these
prizes your award is that you get to
carry a very heavy flag through a long
long procession and some of them are
very heavy indeed so so a little still a
few statistics about the class a fifteen
percent of last year's graduating class
of 2017 many of these will go on to
similar careers but that the class of
2017 about 15 percent began graduate and
professional schools immediately after
graduation another seventy seven percent
were employed so many of these students
already have their plans worked out for
them
[Applause]
so the procession stepped off from
Sterling Memorial Library but Yale has
actually it has 15 main libraries which
houses nearly 15 million print and
electronic volumes including two copies
of the Gutenberg Bible and the Audubon's
Birds of America those can be seen at
the by naki library and so many the
people watching here in New Haven should
should hopefully go and see those they
really are wonderful yes so they are
still massing when believe me when they
come we will know that they are coming
so that mace is this is actually the
pauline murray and that is her flag so
as you could see the gnarled piece of
wood is something that was crafted from
just one piece and it's inscribed with
some of her famous quotes she was a
civil rights activist she fought for
also the inclusion of women as well and
is that Davenport on the other side I
think so
and that that is Franklin Franklin is
then coming along and Benjamin Franklin
like the honor ends today received an
honorary degree from Yale and actually
some of the first founders of Yale sent
Franklin used to send books for those
libraries back from Europe for the Yale
library now you know we haven't really
seen the graduate and professional
schools yet but we will be seeing them
and it takes a long time to get the 1360
Yale undergraduates through and I think
they're just about through by the way
the order changes of who marches first
and who marches last right so if a
College March first this year they're
going to march last next year right so
it isn't equitable to everybody in the
college but it's equitable to the
colleges so some more fun facts actually
are that students in this Yale College
class of 2018 are from 50 different
states in 53 foreign car
trees so which every state is
represented that's okay
point of pride I think and 53 countries
Yale is so international now and so much
more heterogeneous in every way than
when I came here 45 years ago so it's
tremendously tremendously vibrant and
people who were in the audience today
have come from everywhere some their
first trip to Yale and we're so glad to
be able to give them good weather to
allow them to get a look at the campus
let's talk about some of the majors that
these students have been studying well
now we're seeing for those at home a
picture of the old campus and it's got
thousands of chairs which are awaiting
the graduates so a good part of the
commencement theater is actually taken
up by the graduates and here a very
famous toy was actually invented at Yale
yes the frisbee Yale college students
decided to toss pie plates from the
frisbee pie company to each other and
called frisbee to warn passers-by the
spelling was changed when whammo became
mass producing it but who knew Yale
invented the frisbee we're seeing a
picture here of Phelps Gate waiting
waiting on the procession the old campus
of course is now heavily filling up with
family it may be a little hot in places
but I don't think we can complain very
much about the weather
now unfortunately yesterday's classmate
had to be moved inside because we had
predictions of lightning so these these
events will go on whether it's raining
or not but lightning is just too unsafe
so we moved it inside and of course the
Sun ended up coming out anyway right now
everybody is gathering around the green
the undergraduates are making long lines
around the green and at Sterling
Memorial Library the procession
is probably about to start they think
they actually have started they will be
moving through the graduate schools who
have moved up right so they will be
moving through and eventually when they
go to the green which is very symbolic
because the what happens is the students
march through the New Haven green it's a
testimony to the founding of Yael Yael
based in New Haven and the trustees and
the honor ends will march through them
and the green is quite special because
New Haven established these these nine
squares including the Green when it was
first established it was actually the
first planned Missa polity in the United
States and it was established in 1638
can we hear the music from afar you can
yes of the of the band leading the
corporation the trustees and the honor
ends we also have a lot of international
students so there's actually over 4,400
international students and scholars
representing 118 countries at Yale the
graduate schools Arts and Sciences has
the highest proportion of those
international students at about 35% yeah
although I will say that Yale College is
now very very International and it's 35
percent I believe minority and it has a
significant proportion of international
students who all receive need-based aid
which is extraordinary only a number of
colleges and universities are able to do
that and some we feel so lucky that
we're able to do that and to bring into
a Yale College class and of course into
the graduate and professional schools
people from all around the world so the
crowds here today between the students
and families and actually number about
10,000 which is really incredible it
takes the the community at Yale the the
staff and as you can see all the cameras
and it's actually 10,000 for class day
and actually it doubles for commencement
20,000 today well it takes weeks to set
up all of the facilities that are needed
for to accommodate 20,000 people yeah it
there's a great team of facilities
people without whom this could not
happen and a great team of people who
make commencement happen I will say
though that depending on the speaker
class day has had as many as 18,000
people and often has 17 or 18,000 people
and there are actually 18,000 chairs
here today so of course some of them are
filled by undergraduates and graduate
students and professional students but
the cold campus does hold 18,000 chairs
right so there's also some a number of
traditions occurred yesterday besides
hats there is a tradition of planting
the class IV which was in its sat that
actually was established in 1852 and
when the first vine was placed near the
wall the old library now Dwight Memorial
Chapel
so students engraved the the numbers of
their class on a nearby stone yes so
that is again an undergraduate thing but
the undergraduates when they graduate
inscribed their class somewhere on the
old campus very often around Phelps gate
which is where 2018 shows and under it
they plant some Ivy that's symbolic
because of course we don't let ivy climb
our buildings anymore they destroy our
buildings but they symbolically plan ivy
where it cannot climb the buildings in
addition this is a this year is a great
anniversary the Condors anniversary of
the admission of women at at the Medical
School and in 9 2019 we will is 50 years
since the admission of women at Yale
College and it's also about a hundred
and fifty years ago that women were
first admitted to the art school at Yale
it's very interesting because
three of the four leaders of class day
yesterday were women and to class state
chairs for next year will be women and
with Hillary Clinton speaking yesterday
there was a vibrant feminist field to it
shared by everybody men and women alike
and anywhere
she's an alum of you she is an alum of
Yale Law School yes and we look forward
next year as you say to the 50th
anniversary of women admitted to Yale
College and the 150th two women admitted
somewhere at Yale um the art school very
early on had had several women so this
was of course much earlier than the
undergraduate and the law school even
before in the 30s I believe had its
first woman so the other the arms of
Yale actually has six different types of
color although everyone remembers the
Yale blue but there are actually other
colors you're also gonna see a collar a
special robe that the president of Yale
president Peter salivate will be wearing
in the procession it's gold silver and
also enamel and it's there are eleven
cloyce own and Charlie Brown dales they
bear the arms of the Graduate School in
the professional schools and also three
shields bearing the arms of the
University and Yale College and the
Great Seal of the United States so the
the president's robe itself is very
simple and very I'm told very hard to
put on it has several layers of things
that need to be adjusted and tied and
put on but essentially it's almost a
Puritan rope but then he wears this very
expensive and beautiful piece of jewelry
that you have just described with the
names of the schools all around it and a
big jewel in the middle this is part of
the celebration that the you
versity does of its graduates and of
course of itself to mark a moment in
which its graduates go off to lead and
serve in the wider world and by the way
the first graduation at Yale 17:02 when
for students in Saybrook before Yale had
moved to New Haven four students
received MA degrees and ma honor and
good degrees so commencements are a very
old tradition have happened from time
immemorial and this one of course is the
317 another fact about the president's
can't let go of the collar but it looks
it's gonna look like a necklace really
is that from it is suspended a jewel
that's composed of a pair of carved and
polished glass medallions and the gold
mountings for the Jewelers set also with
Khoisan enamel plaques which bear the
Hebrew characters referring to the
sacred lots of the Bible and the
university's motto looksie Veritas yeah
it's light and truth and we see here on
the old campus some faculty beginning to
arrive now who is it that you're going
to see on this stage eventually well so
the people that we will see on on the
stage are actually also some the deans
and also the members members of the Tres
Board of Trustees as well as the
officers of the university
administrators there will be several
speakers but mostly it will be the deans
that will come up and and address the
president asking that he confer upon the
students of that school their degrees
well the first row will be the honor
ends yes so you will be able to see the
honor ends very very clearly in the
first row some of the trustees will be
in the second row and then the deans of
the schools all the deans of the
professional schools all the heads of
the red
seneschal colleges all the residents of
all the deans of Yale College and all of
the officers of the university will all
be sitting up here on this stage so step
off actually hasn't happened yet it was
a false alarm but now right right but it
is coming and we will see there you see
Sharon Oster who Sharon Oster is
retiring from the School of Management
and she is one of the important marshals
at this event and pretty soon we should
see the corporation marshal who is Paul
Frye so Sharon was the Dean of the
School of Management for a number of
years and she on her retirement is
giving being given the honor of carrying
this important university mace and
behind her is actually with the with all
of those cameras is Michael Marsland
he's been the University of photographer
for 40 years but he still comes back to
photograph special events like this one
and behind them I can see the President
and I can see the officers and some of
the trustees are all their president is
tipping his hat there and you see that
jewel he's wearing above his very simple
but complicated robe and there is Kim
Gough Cruz the secretary of the
university I see and trust Scott Strobel
the officers of the University and there
is Sharon carrying them so the mace it's
pretty interesting it's a heavy ivory
knob with a brass shield inset and it
bears the engraved inscription horace
andrews from class 1841 in that era each
class select is it bully or cheek
defender and supplied him with the
appropriate weapon and I see Ben [ __ ]
the Provost walking with the president
Kim Gough Cruz
find him Scott's trouble is trying to
spot the honor ends here should we say a
word about the honor yes no so be on the
lookout for Angela Bassett who is
receiving a is it a Doctor of Fine Arts
and there's Neil deGrasse Tyson I see
Neil deGrasse Tyson who is the Doctor of
Humane Letters you should also see
Elizabeth Alexander there she is right
in the middle and she was a professor
here at Yale but she is receiving a
Doctor of Letters and Rick Lifton who
was also a professor at Yale is now the
head of the Rockefeller Institute and he
is receiving a doctor of Medical
Sciences oh there's Eve rice from the
goodies of corporation members and
former corporation members here we also
have Willie ruff who just passed in the
lower part of the screen a longtime
professor here he's getting an honorary
degree doctor of music there you see
here come CL College this is Yale
College with the Yale College flag we
see Dean Chun the Dean of Yale College
the senior deans mark Schenker Jane
Edwards there's jeremiah quinlan the
Dean of Admissions Pam sure Meister and
all the senior and assistant Dean's of
Yale College are marching behind the
corporation the cultural deans Eileen
Galvez I see there and Julianne
Yee and now School of Engineering and
Applied Sciences is passing right now so
some of the other honor ants beside
those we've mentioned Fran's de Waal is
is receiving a Doctor of social science
he's a biologist whose research has shed
new light and the social behavior and
cognitive abilities of non-human
primates Laura Mulvey is one of the
great figures in the history
theory she's a professor of film at
Birkbeck College University of London
she's been very influential in
developing the field of feminist film
theory she's inspired generations of
scholars at Yale and around the world
can also be on the lookout for Judea
pearl he was receiving a doctor of
engineering and technology he's a
pioneer of cognitive computing what
we're hearing a lot about artificial
intelligence and on the left here you
see the School of Medicine wearing their
green afters after science and
engineering and the Graduate School of
Arts - Sciences on the right I see em
know that's Emily Baker the provost
maybe maybe it's not the graduate school
yet but on the left is certainly the
School of Medicine you'll also see one
of our honor ends and clerical robes
although they'll probably be covered up
it's the Rowan Williams who is the
distinguished theologian the here's the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
yeah on the right with their blue
new PhD they're going to be giving 703
degrees today and all of these schools
will soon be entering here as soon as
they get here they will be enter year
and meanwhile around the green are all
the undergraduates
I think the people who are doing this
make an effort to have families who are
not here see every face going on you
know a quarter gate it means so much to
people when they can actually see their
own students they will get a very very
good view of course so after the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences the
law school we coming through School of
Management we saw the School of Medicine
the School of Music School of Nursing
public health
we haven't seen anybody enter here yet
well here we come here come here come
some of the faculty are entering I see
yes Mina Becerra vich from the Graduate
School the marshal and they're now
beginning to find their seats in the
front here the faculty are beginning to
find their seats
so the faculty marshals that was Phillip
Bernstein was for the architecture
school mark Gibson was for the art
school and divinity was Chloe Starr
drama was Victoria Nolan forestry and
environmental studies Julie Zimmerman I
see the marshals from the graduate
school I see and Gaylen here and they're
all beginning to file in with other
faculty so with the faculty you can see
the many colored robes and hoods that we
talked about before I see blue robes
from Yale
I see robes from Cornell I see robes
from Berkeley
I see robes from MIT and as I said
before people are wearing robes that
represent the schools from which they
receive their incoming terminal degrees
in medicine coming here we see medicine
and you'll see the tassels on the hats
the Gold's represents PhD degrees and
those the black the caps are black as
are the tassels for Bachelors of Arts
and Bachelors of Science
so on the screen we're seeing the School
of Medicine while in the commencement
theater we're seeing filling in
beginning some of the marshals and some
of the faculty from some of the schools
there's a total of 168 degrees from the
School of Medicine and 104 are doctors
of medicine today 124
so those are so orange I think which
engineering is orange a nursing is a
papercut and I can't tell whether that's
Lauren it's hard to taught either
actually but we definitely see the
Graduate School of Arts and Science
so the forestry hats are starting to
come in and they are always a hit oh
here they come here they come flowers
some of them have this is forestry and
environmental studies and on their
mortar boards you're seeing all kinds of
forestry I would say and also in marine
life and animals this looks like the
nursing school yes I believe it is with
old fashioned nursing caps on top of
their hats
and over here on our right we can see
that the school of medicine is actually
filing in we're seeing yeah they are
School of Medicine congratulations to
all of you
doctors we're happy to see you so 124
new doctors and so nursing as we saw
before the nursing schools that the
nursing students there's be a hundred
and sixteen nursing degrees given out in
the nursing school today I don't see
them pilot filing and I've seen them
filing into it yeah yeah it takes a long
time to process and fill up this old
campus which we're lucky enough does
hold 20,000 shares almost twenty
thousand these are the law students
which you could see is the purple hood
which signifies a law degree if people
watched yesterday and saw Hillary
Clinton speak she had she had on her
Yale degree black robe with purple with
her purple hood just as yours is
we see the Dean of the School of
Medicine here is coming towards the
towards of the stage she's nice and age
[Applause]
lots of groups and cheers for the
students as they come in to all campus
and we're seeing some science hoods in
yellow and the law students in purple
and here come the flag here comes the
photo enjoy commencement everyone we
love being here with you have a great
day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to the students of the class of 2018 and
their parents families and friends
welcome to the 317th commencement of
Yale University we gather to recognize
the extraordinary accomplishments of all
of you who have worked so hard to
complete your programs of study we
salute your effort your diligence your
talent and your intellect we also join
you in expressing gratitude for all who
have supported you in these endeavors
your families and friends your teachers
and other members of the Yale community
in keeping with the tradition of this
occasion I now call on the University
chaplain to offer an invocation with
deep gratitude to the Quinnipiac people
for this land on which we stand
my beloved Yale family I invite you to
join me in the spirit of prayer Almighty
and loving creator you are the force
that lights the Stars the architect of
every cell the source of all truth we
stand in the dazzling beauty of this
morning as many expressions of one
living mystery a mystery beyond all
telling
as students of your handiwork we have
gathered here from throughout the earth
with exquisite ambitions and have been
blessed at this place of light and truth
with the freedom to let them grow our
God of all generations you are the
guardian of where we are going and who
we are becoming
we who share this beautiful but aching
world we who look at the same Sun and
the same moon are a people called to
communal restoration as we prepare to
take leave of this place we may we exude
an intelligence that is inspired by
justice guided by tenderness moved by
holiness and always informed by love
from this moment on fill our hearts with
an imaginative daring one that stirs us
to become living vibrant examples of
Shalom of Salaam of Shanti of peace
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the bachelor's
degrees in Yale College for the degree
of Bachelor of Arts 857 in number and
for the degree of Bachelor of Science
422 in number they have been recommended
by the Faculty of Yale College and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the bachelors degrees in Yale
College as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Architecture for the degree of
Master of Architecture seventy-seven in
number and for the degree Master of
Environmental Design - in number
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in
architecture and design as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
school of art for the degree of Master
of Fine Arts 59 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them this degree by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degree in art as designated by the Dean
and admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Drama for the certificate in
drama five and number four the degree of
Master of Fine Arts fifty eight in
number and for the degree of Doctor of
Fine Arts three in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
certificate and degrees in drama as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the degrees in
the School of Music for the artists
diploma one in number for the degree of
Master of Music
71 in number for the degree Master of
Musical Arts 32 in number and for the
degree Doctor of Musical Arts 8 in
number they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the Diploma and degrees
in music as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Nursing
[Applause]
degree of Master of Science in Nursing
97 in number and for the degree of
Doctor of Nursing Practice 14 in number
they have them recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them this
degree by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in nursing
as designated by the Dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the degrees in
the School of Forestry and environmental
studies for the degree of Master of
Forestry 12 in number for the degree of
Master of forest science 5 in number for
the degree of master of environmental
management a hundred and twelve in
number and for the degree of master of
environmental science 24 in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and improved by the
corporation I ask you now by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in forestry
and environmental studies as designated
by the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Management for the degree of
Master of Business Administration 397 in
number for the degree of Master of
Advanced Management 62 in number and for
the degree of Master in Management
Studies 6 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
invested or 'ti vested in me I confer
upon you the degrees in management as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
Divinity School for the degree of Master
of Arts in religion 77 in number for the
degree of Master of Divinity 49 in
number and for the degree of Master a
sacred theology 9 in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degrees in religion divinity and
theology as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
law school for the degree of Master of
studies in law - in number for the
degree of Juris Doctor 208 in number for
the degree of Master of Laws
twenty-three in number and for the
degree of Doctor of the science of law
three in number when they had been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I shall
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I shall confer upon you the
degrees in the law school when
designated by the Dean and shall then
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
graduate school for the degree of Master
of Science 153 in number for the degree
of Master of Arts 189 and number for the
degree of Master of Advanced Studies 1
in number and for the degree of Master
of Philosophy 132 in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degrees in the Graduate School as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Public Health for the degree
of Master of Public Health 139 in number
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them this
degree by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degree in public
health as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Medicine
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of Master of Medical
Science 37 in number when they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I shall
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them this degree for the degree of
Master of Health Science forty-one in
number for the degree of Doctor of
Medicine 124 in number
[Applause]
and for the dig for the certificate in
global health three in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I shall confer
the degree in medical science and do
confer upon you the certificate and
degrees in health science medicine and
global medicine as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
[Music]
[Applause]
crisis Clary seem a
[Applause]
Candida tosod gradum philosophy Artorius
numero deux kenty sexagon Thao news TV
presenter a faculty at a filosophy I
Artem Quay at Sonata académico
illustrate our probity soon tell Dom in
a row goooood aisles are dwunk Graydon
Anita's secundum legis Boram quoi una
where citta des Nostra was a guram
philosophy i doctores emitter whoa this
way wanna come hook diplomatic your illa
earthquake dignity at ease
qui air honk on or inspect n't conferral
nonk
studious felicity absolutists ago prayer
Isis universitatis was X animal you bear
Sol where a at Valeri
[Applause]
[Music]
we will now proceed to the awarding of
honorary degrees the 10 individuals we
honor this morning serve as examples to
you our graduates to encourage you to
aspire to excellence and to value those
elements of human character that they
embody creativity curiosity discipline
innovation integrity and a passion for
social justice their presence here also
honors you who graduate today and all of
us who are here to salute you
I will now as is customary call upon the
Provost to present the candidates for
honorary degrees mr. president I have
the honor to present the candidates for
honorary degrees for the doctor of music
Willie Roth musician and scholar
Willie ruff you have shared the wonders
of music with the world introducing new
audiences to the transcendent power of
jazz you discover the echoes of distant
times and faraway places in this
quintessential American art form in your
conservatory without walls generations
of young people have been inspired by
jazz legend scholar storyteller and
musicians in gratitude for your
creativity and charisma we are
privileged to present your third Yale
degree doctor of music
[Applause]
[Music]
for the degree of Doctor of humanities
Laura Mulvey theorist and filmmaker
Laura Mulvey your path-breaking theories
of film have given us new ways to
examine our culture and ourselves
crossing boundaries and weaving
disciplines you showed us the male gaze
and opened fresh territory in the study
of gender media and society as a
filmmaker you have defied conventions
and produce daring works of art scholar
artisan teacher and feminist we are
honored to present you with this Doctor
of humanities degree
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of Medical
Sciences
Richard liftin physician and scientists
[Applause]
Richard liftin your research has
improved countless lives you have
advanced our understanding of the
genetics of disease accelerating the
pace of discovery at our University and
beyond your findings have led to better
treatment and prevention for millions of
patients with hypertension research
pioneer and gifted scientist and
recognition of your trailblazing
contributions to human health
we proudly bestow on you this doctor of
Medical Sciences degree
for the degree of Doctor of Letters
Elizabeth Alexander writer and educator
Elizabeth Alexander your words are
radiant illuminating our world anew from
Cape Town to London from Harlan Harlem
to this nation's capital your verse and
prose circle the globe exploring family
intimacy loss and struggle and you have
said it plain in front of millions
elevating the human voice in history
generous teacher brave artist in praise
for your songs of hope and truth we are
honored to present you with your third
Yale degree Doctor of Letters
[Applause]
[Music]
for the degree of Doctor of Divinity
Rowan Williams theologian Rowan Williams
with wisdom and humility you nurture
dialogue and understanding in our
fragile world from the pages of ancient
scriptures and in daily communion with
the human family you seek answers to
life's great mysteries and you live your
faith in service to others reminding us
to love and care for our neighbors
especially the most vulnerable among us
voice of hope scholar of light and truth
we are humbled to present you with this
Doctor of Divinity degree
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of engineering
and technology judea pearl computer
scientists
[Applause]
Judea pearl your discoveries have
extended the frontiers of human
knowledge with elegant equations and
imaginative models you have transformed
our understanding of cause-and-effect
probability and uncertainty your
insights unlock complex puzzles while
opening new areas for exploration
marvelous mathematician fearless
innovator in appreciation for all that
your work has made possible we are
privileged to bestow on you this Doctor
of engineering and Technology degree
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters Neil deGrasse Tyson
astrophysicist
neil degrasse tyson you have led us on
journeys through interstellar space
helping us comprehend the complexity of
the cosmos with you we have explored the
wonders of the known world and been
humbled by what is yet unknown no
question is too vast no problem too
intricate for your curiosity bright star
in humanity's sky for showing us how
science can explain the splendors of our
universe and enlighten our minds we are
honored to bestow on you this Doctor of
Humane Letters degree
[Applause]
for the degree of Doctor of Letters
Marilyn Robinson novelist and essayist
Marilyn Robinson in routine chores and
lovely rituals in the richness of the
past and in living miracles you evoke
all the beauty and devastation of our
mortal world with concern for the common
good an alert to the great unfilled
promise of democracy your essays and
novels have led us to new understandings
of ourselves
sacred profane and full of grace as we
are in gratitude for your lifetime of
creation we proudly confer on you this
Doctor of Letters degree
[Applause]
for the degree of doctor of social
science Fran's de Waal biologists and
primatologist
[Applause]
Fran's de Waal with empathy and
imagination you challenge our
understanding of the animal kingdom and
our place in it among chimpanzees and
bonobos you have discovered compassion
generosity and intelligence diminishing
the divide between humans and our
primate relatives scientist and
interpreter for helping us see a greater
capacity for kindness and cooperation in
our world and in ourselves we are
privileged to present you with this
doctor of social science degree
and for the degree of Doctor of Fine
Arts Angela Evelyn Bassett actress
[Applause]
angela bassett chameleon of film
television and stage you have brought
American icons from Tina Turner to
Coretta Scott King to life and in the
process become an icon yourself as
mother to trade Styles Christopher
Wallace T'Challa
and the Jackson 5 as a stockbroker a
housekeeper and a queen you have
inspired us and challenged us actress of
range and power in recognition of your
superb Talent
Yale is privileged to present you with
your third Yale degree Doctor of Fine
Arts
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gracious God you who are beyond us yet
within us who are imperceptible yet
known to us who are other but our part
of us may these graduates see the divine
in all may they have the creativity to
overturn entrenched in justices and the
magnanimity of heart to forgive may they
see what others have examined but not
perceived may they imagine what has not
been dreamed and heal the incurable
thank you for every graduate and their
family for this orb that we inhabit and
for this home that we know as Yale all
men
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]